as for content the other side make it
makes it easy enough for themselves at
times to display a great expanse of it
they appropriate a lot of already
familiar and well ordered material by
focusing on rare and exotic instances
they give the impression they have hold
on everything which scientific knowledge
had already embraced in its scope and
that they're also in command of such
material as is yet unordered it thus
appears that everything has been
subjected to the absolute idea which
therefore seems to be cognizant
everything into a matured into an
expanded science but a closer inspection
shows that this expansion has not come
about through one in the same principle
having spontaneously assumed different
shapes but rather through the shapeless
repetition of one in the same formula
only externally applied to diverse
materials thereby obtaining merely a
boring show of diversity the idea which
is of course true enough on its own
account remains in effect always in its
primitive condition if its development
involves nothing more than this sort of
repetition of the same formula well the
knowing subject goes around applying
this single inert form to whatever it
encounters and dipping the material into
this placid element from outside this is
no more the fulfillment of what is
needed that is a self originating self
differentiating wealth of shapes than
any arbitrary insights into the content
rather it is a monochromatic formalism
which only arrives at the
differentiation of its material since
this has already been provided and is by
now familiar
so now we come to
new section where we're going to a
different side of this bifurcation and
he says as for content is what we're
really interested in here the other side
make it easy enough for themselves to
display a great expansively so which
other side are we talking at that are we
talking about the other side meaning the
side of the big-picture intuition that
we were just looking at a moment ago or
are we talking about the side that may
not have a grasp on you know where it's
actually going overall but at least can
hunker down and make sense out of things
by looking at the interplay between form
and content by organizing the things
that it empirically studies here's an
interesting thing to think about really
this could apply to both of them why
because they're both trying to overcome
that that gap that we saw in in between
them the the side of the big picture the
big idea now has to actually make good
on that by showing that it can actually
apply to a number of different types of
content that it can take it in and
organize it the other side has got to
show that it can actually make good on
saying well what the hell are you
actually doing how do you understand
this activity of classifying of
differentiating and organizing that
you've been engaged in what is your
actual findings what is the meaning of
what you're up to
so he says that the the they can display
a great expanse of content and here's
one of the fundamental questions that
you have to engage with if you're trying
to think about things in any sort of
systematic manner when you're studying
something something that you don't fully
know how do you in fact grasp how do you
get to the information and then how do
you articulate it articulating means how
do
you organize it how do you structure it
how do you classify it how do you
differentiate things from each other
how do you decide what's most relevant
and what's least relevant how do you
figure out what's most determinative and
what's the determined how do you figure
out where causality runs those are all
ways of articulating content I may go
hand-in-hand because it's not as if you
just first get the content and then
start figuring out how everything is
connected the real way in which we
experience things even if we're carrying
out the most careful research is these
are all kind of mixed up together we
have to work a bit to disentangle them
and notice I put content and then
contents here and I underlined the
plural making ask why did I do that
because it's one thing to study a
particular type of content it's another
to deal with things that are what we
call heterogeneous that means that
they're of a different genre they don't
fit in with each other so you know we
ought to be really suspicious in our own
time and we see people making claims
about brain science and morality because
those are two very different ranges or
even brain science and the emotions
because the emotions you know are they
simple things are they just chemistry
are they just interactions among neurons
and you know hormones and external
stimuli what is there more but you know
there's something more going on there
are they're multi levels to these these
phenomena if there are then we have to
have multiple ways of approaching
different kinds of content and we have
to be a bit more careful about what
we're doing we don't want to shove
everything into the same box there's
that old expression that to the man of
the Hammer Every Problem looks like a
nail you don't want to be that guy if
you're actually trying to do science
because remember what is science
supposed to do it's supposed to study
the whole and to study it in all of its
aspects parts features
and make sense of it now if you're only
studying things under one lens you sure
can't study the whole Canyon because
everything starts to look the same so
this is a real deep question how do you
deal with multiple contents how do you
deal with the fact that the same content
may in fact be able to be looked at in
very different aspects it may have
multiple sides multiple facets to it
those are important questions here's
another question how do you read
articulate what the people before you
who were engaged in something and let's
say that what they were doing was was
scientific but just not as scientific
how do you make sense out of what they
did so you don't have to reinvent the
wheel each time and so you can actually
incorporate their work and transcend
what was false in it and incorporate
what was true in it that's what Hegel is
grasping in this as the central problem
he says so this this sight makes it easy
enough to display a great expanse of
content they appropriate a lot of
familiar and well ordered material
focusing on rare and exotic instances
they give the impression they have hold
of everything which scientific knowledge
had already embraced in its scope so
they give the impression that they've
taken in everything that previous
science has already given us they fully
understood it
they've assimilated it they've digested
it they've made it their own
and they're also in command of such
material as is yet unordered so they've
solved this problem too they figured out
how I'm going to get to all the things I
don't know and figure out exactly what
slots they go into because we know all
the slots it's just a matter of like
finding the the stuff to put into those
slots so he says they give the
appearance that everything has been
subjected to the absolute idea which
therefore seems to be cognized in
everything to maturity to an experience
and so they they give the impression of
having police solved all of these issues
and they may not actually make the claim
that everything is totally solved but
they'll say look we finally figured out
the method we have carried out the
Copernican revolution that there have
been many different Copernican
revolution now haven't there that turned
everything on its head and now it's all
downhill work from here baby that's the
impression that efforts yeah science
that aren't fully aware of what they're
doing that's the impression that they
give because they believe that's the
case but what have they done here I
didn't have to erase a little bit how
they really succeeded and what it is
that they purport to have done or to be
able to do can they make good on their
promises now of course you know this is
graphic representation so really the
whole lot to be the integrity of the
chalkboard but I just want to have you
know some sort of bounded thing so the
science is supposed to be taking in the
whole yeah I'm gonna leave science sort
of on the boundary right here because
it's still not that completely clarify
whether science is something
transcendent to the whole you know the
the subjective observer is outside of it
or whether they should be considered
part of it that's going to come about in
some of them later discussions here's
what Hegel says they do
they take one basic conception and then
they superimpose that on all the content
of that hole so if they're using
medicine everything looks like a medical
problem everything has to be solved that
way if there are a physicist everything
can be reduced to two you know physical
properties and the basic forces and
particles if they're a sort of bigger
picture kind of thing you know let's say
there is sociologists everything becomes
a sociological problem everything is
sociological categories as a matter of
fact even knowledge the knowledge that
the physicists think that they have
those are just constructs you see where
this is going
what they do like Hegel says is they
they their expansion into the hole has
not come about through one of the same
it is not come about through one of the
same principle having spontaneously
assumed different shapes so this range
of being requires a basic conception but
a basic conception that can take on
another shape another form another mode
of articulation and some of what they do
is they just apply the same cookie
cutter to everything he says rather
through the shapeless repetition of one
in the same formula only externally
applied to diverse materials thereby
obtaining a boring show of diversity and
that that word boring there is really
amped because there's no better way to
describe the person who's writing their
disciplinary hobbyhorse
all over roughshod every bit of thing
you could think about it's boring to
talk to somebody who thinks that
everything is physics it's boring to
talk to somebody who thinks that
everything is logic it's boring to talk
to somebody who thinks that everything
is a technological problem to be solved
it's boring to talk to somebody who can
only talk about politics there are
one-trick pony why is that so boring
this is just cuz they repeat themselves
no cuz they could they could talk about
a lot of different stuff it's because we
have this innate drive this hunger to
use a word that Hegel's gonna use later
the gear the desire to know reality and
reality doesn't just come in one flavor
as a matter of fact it doesn't just come
in flavors it comes in tones it comes in
shapes and sizes
it comes in hardness and softness it
comes in everything across the entire
range that you could possibly think
about that is reality so having just one
way of making sense of that one lens
through which to view at all that's
going to be very boring and it's going
to be very boring because it's very
artificial it's in many respects dead so
he says the idea which is of course true
on its own account remains always in its
primitive condition it doesn't develop
in this case well what makes it develop
is when you actually have to apply
yourself to different content this is
why Renaissance people are so
interesting because they've actually
mastered different fields and they
didn't just look at them it has all the
same even if you're like you know great
at languages one of the things that will
make you great at languages you don't
expect every language to be similar to
the other one you don't expect
everything to be mutually translatable
you don't just walk in and say all right
what's the syntax
what's the grammar I just want to learn
this this form and now give me the
vocabulary and all right now I speak
Swahili doesn't work like that
you actually have to and this is going a
little bit beyond what Hegel Sanger but
I think this is a very important point
you have to have a sort of relationship
of if not at least not love at least
desire to engage with what it is that
you're
to study and this is going to be
different from this and this part is
going to be different from this the
human body will be different than
society will be different than
technology will be different than animal
in a purely animal behavior which will
be different than particle physics you
can't use the same basic one single idea
to make sense of them all that sort of
reductionism is boring so he says when
the knowing subject goes are on applying
the single inert form of whatever it
encounters and dipping the material into
this placid element from the outside
this is no more the fulfillment of what
is needed what is needed Hegel thinks
that science has needs
it has needs because it's human subjects
who are engaged in it and those human
subjects are using science to get to
know about things to understand things
and to understand themselves and
understand their location in time and
history and in the whole realm of
meaning so this this you know this
doesn't fulfill us because what do we
need a self originating self
differentiating wealth of shapes and he
talks about he talks about this is a
monochromatic formalism what does that
mean
it's it paints the whole world one color
could be gray could be pink could be
whatever your favorite color is but
guaranteed if you paint everything that
color you're gonna get pretty sick of it
before too long because some things are
just not going to fit that and you're
not going to be able to really tell
anything apart from anything else
yet this formalism maintains that such
monotony and abstract universality are
the absolute and we are assured that
dissatisfaction with it indicates the
inability to master the absolute
standpoint and to keep hold of it
time was when the bare possibility of
imagining something differently was
sufficient to refute an idea and this
bare possibility this general thought
also had the entire positive value of of
an into an actual cognition nowadays we
see all value ascribed to the universal
idea in this non actual form and the
undoing of all distinct determinate
entities or rather the hurling of all of
them into the abyss of acuity without
further development or any justification
is allowed to pass muster as the
speculative mode of treatment dealing
with something from the perspective of
the absolute consists merely in
declaring that although one has been
speaking of it just now as something
definite yet in the absolute the a
equals a there is nothing of the kind
for they're all as one to pick this
single insight that in the absolute
everything is the same against the full
body of articulated cognition which at
least seeks and demand such fulfillment
to Palm off it's absolute as the night
in which as the saying goes all calls
are black this is cognition night
naively reduced to vacuity the formalism
which recent philosophy denounces and
despises only to see it reappear in its
midst will not vanish from science
however much its inadequacy may be
recognized and felt till the cognizant
of absolute actuality has become
entirely clear as to its own nature
since the presentation of a general idea
and outline before any attempt to follow
it out in detail makes the latter
attempt easier to grasp it may be useful
at this point to give a rough idea of it
at the same time taking the opportunity
to get rid of certain habits of thought
which impede philosophical cognition
in section 16 we now come to the famous
passage about the night in which all
cows are black and that's a really great
catchphrase but what is it really about
what is Hegel criticizing there so a lot
of commentators will steer us towards
the German idealist of his own time in
particular his close associate who he
worked with quite a bit and was somewhat
in the shadow of and that's that's
shelling and shelling his philosophy if
you look at Hegel's construe love it his
philosophy is really not that successful
of a project and it does seem to fit
this formalism that he's talking about
but really consul asif ii fits this as
well and i think that we can go far
beyond this and see that you know the
sort of thing that we were looking at in
the last passage the the idea that we
can take one disciplinary way of looking
at things and extend it to everything
all reality and say that we don't need
to really develop the science any
further we don't need to develop the
discipline any further and we can we
grasp the totality
that's the formalism that he's talking
about so that's kind of timeless that's
going to come up over and over and over
again so let's look at what he starts
out with he talks about the absolute in
this case and the way in which these
people portray the absolute is in
Hegel's eyes a false understanding of
the absolute it's not really doing the
absolute justice to reduce it to a kind
of monotony kind of as he says a equals
a or this is the statement of identity a
thing is what it is the whole is what it
is the death or the nucleus or the
whatever it is that that underlies that
we think that's what it is and that's
that's all that you got and then over
here on this side we have experience
which is determinate which is of things
that exist that interact with each
they're that are distinct from each
other and that are differentiated from
each other and which differentiate
themselves from each other that are
connected in particular relations and
what's the problem with this this is
that model chromaticism that he was
talking about if we take this
perspective on the absolute then all of
this really doesn't matter I mean you
can you can have your own little
experience but it's all really going to
be the same because it's all in the same
absolute everything is in the absolute
so he says this is the the night in
which all all cows are black how they're
distinct things and they're wandering
around and I suppose it you know if you
bump into them you're gonna know that if
they are you here move you're gonna know
that they're there but it doesn't do you
any good because you can't see it you
can't differentiate them yeah I suppose
if you were blind you could say well I'm
at an advantage when it comes to cows in
a dark night but Hegel is saying here
this is just not going to work this is
not going to be a successful way for
philosophy to conduct itself to make
sense out of its own project and he's
building up to kind of a crescendo here
notice that he's been carrying out he
started out the preface by saying yeah
you can't really read a philosophical
preface because you know everyone
expects you to like you know put all the
main stuff in and just leave all the
content out and that doesn't work for
philosophy and here's why because
philosophy has to be something where
there's a dynamic engagement between the
content and the form and and let me move
into all these criticisms and he spent a
lot of time on the criticism of the you
know notion of relying on intuition and
this fuzzy can hazy sentimentality and
then you know this this notion of
science as something that just you know
takes in information sort of
indiscriminately and kind of ordered it
if it doesn't really know what it's
doing with it and then this this
transcendental idea of the absolutely
you know this may as well be the
conscient thing in itself that because
you can't really do anything with it
doesn't get you anywhere so what is
going to get us somewhere he says that
what we want to avoid is hurling things
into vacuity and what does that mean
hurling things into emptiness into
meaninglessness we don't want to reduce
our experience to meaninglessness and we
don't want the absolute to become
something meaningless in the process
instead of what we're going to have to
do is bring together the experiential
the historical the developmental there
is going to have to be an interplay
between the two that's the only way in
which the absolute is actually going to
be something more than abstract
universality we don't want to abstract
universality we want concrete
universality we want something
determinate something that we can see
and you can say well then you're asking
for something that simply can't be
provided at this point or any point the
very notion of a universal means it has
to be abstract Hegel is on the scene to
say how do you know that are you sure
about that let's actually give this a
try and see whether not only can it
happen but perhaps it's already been
happening all this time that's what the
bulk of this book the phenomenology all
these pages this entire work is about
its retracing the steps of that and he
says so it's the presentation of a
general idea and outline before any
attempt to follow it out in detail makes
the latter attempt easier to grasp I'm
going to try to give you a rough idea of
it and at the same time taking the
opportunity to try to get rid of some
bad habits and bad mental habits some
assumptions some built-in biases that we
have that can impede philosophical
cognition
in my view which can be justified only
by the exposition of the system itself
everything turns on grasping and
expressing the true not only a substance
but equally and subject at the same time
it is to be observed that substantiality
embraces the universal or the immediacy
of knowledge itself as well as that
which is being or immediacy for
knowledge
if the conception of God is the one
substance shock the age in which it was
proclaimed the reason for this was on
the one hand an instinctive awareness
that in this definition
self-consciousness was only submerged
and not preserved on the other hand the
opposite view which claims the thought
is such - universality as such is the
very same simplicity as undifferentiated
unmoved substantiality and if thirdly
thought does unite itself with the being
of substance and apprehends immediacy or
intuition is thinking the question is
still whether this intellectual
intuition does not again fall back into
inert simplicity and does not depict
actuality itself in a non actual manner
a lot of people get excited about
section 16 because of the you know night
in which all cows are black metaphor
which is you gotta admit you know a
great turn of phrase this is one of the
sections that I think is really key
there's a ton of stuff that's being
prefigured here and Hegel's starting to
lay out some of his cards on the table
remember in the previous section he just
said alright I'm gonna tell you a little
bit about where we're going now I'm
actually gonna start doing a preface and
I'm gonna try to wean us away from some
of the bad habits of thought that are
gonna keep us from making progress
on this road so he says in my view which
can be justified only by the exposition
of the system itself that we've already
heard that part here's where it gets
really cool the grasping or the
expressing and I there's a reason why I
put one above the other of the true he
has to take place not only as substance
but as something else
we'll come to that in just a moment so
let's let's think about this grasping
the truth grasping truth means
apprehending it taking it in being able
to see the true as true grasping and
expressing they're not exactly the same
thing are they but they call to each
other and they're mutually implicated
within each other because if you grasp
something as true you can actually
explain it for Hegel to another person
you're able to express that you're able
to express it at least to yourself
grasping and expressing there is a
already an engagement a dialectic
between them so grasping the truth or a
truth as substance now you know when we
say substance the traditional
metaphysical notion of substance is that
which is most real that which is
fundamental that which literally is is
that which other things are based upon
that's sort of the Aristotelian
conception and that does make sense in
this respect so grasping being
grasping truth as substance but Hegel
says we have to grasp it not only as
substance as that which underlies
everything else but also and subject
that's revolutionary and this is where
you know I'm a huge fan of Aristotle and
so is Hegel by the way and I think that
Hegel and Aristotle actually you know
share quite a lot more in common than
people give them credit for this is one
of the things that's left unthought in
the Aristotle's work and I'm not just
talking about mind you know thinking
itself or thought thinking itself I'm
thinking about the ordinary human being
and the fact that we are you know
substances that are at the same time
subjects and Aristotle doesn't just
think this about individual human beings
he's willing to say that these weren't
substance for this but he talks about
the nature of the thing and this is in
politics book 1 the nature of the thing
is that which it is when it's when it's
completed and what would be examples of
things horse man house and it doesn't
just mean house in the sense of like a
heap of bricks over there Rico's can
also mean you know a mini community
because then he goes on and he talks
about you know greater unities greater
holes so to grasp the true not only as
substance not only as what is most real
or at least what we take to be most real
but also as dynamic as active as being
something like us that's also to grasp
ourselves as being involved in their
substance and subject have a dialectical
relation with each other then he goes on
to talk about what a substantiality
actually
involved or encompass he says that it
encompasses the universal the immediacy
of knowledge and we'll come back to that
in a second and it also encompasses
being or the immediacy for knowledge now
I want to tune you in to the importance
of these two little words they're going
to show up over and over and over this
distinction between the of and the four
or to put it in another way
being in itself being for itself this
this constant back and forth that has to
do with interestingly enough mediation
we're looking at immediacy here which
means the lack of mediation or at least
what appears to be the lack of mediation
at this point but really what we're
talking about is mediation there being
something that acts as a mediating term
that makes something else possible that
conditions it that works with it that we
have to like see is also part of the
process as being involved in this so
substantiality is not just one single
thing it's already encompassing a number
of different aspects or facets here
we're doing some pretty high-level
hardcore metaphysics that's why this
passage is is you know kind of head's
splitting people look at they're like
what the hell is all this stuff about so
substance and subject substantiality the
immediacy of knowledge what does that
mean that means that what we know
presents itself to us as if it's just
there we know it we know it has this and
that's all there is to it there's no
more to the story being that which were
actually knowing not just the universal
through which we're knowing being is a
deeper form of immediacy
knowledge which then shows us that
knowledge is mediating being being gives
itself to us this is what substance
means being gives itself to us as
something that our knowledge which is
through universals is related to and the
Universalist sort of like the medium the
the term through which we grasp what's
actually out there now how does that
work when we're talking about not just
substance like what this piece of truck
is but subject when we're talking about
ourselves and Hegel here talks about God
why is he talking about God in this
context he says if the conception of God
is the one substance shock the age in
which it was proclaimed why would that
that shock an age because we're moving
from substance being something like
crime you know whatever prime matter is
going to be or in the case of well it's
water or the elements or who knows what
to being something that is a subject
active if you take the you know
traditional Jewish Christian Muslim
monotheistic conception of God as that
which is most real God is a subject not
just the divine substance so it says the
reason for this was on the one hand an
instinctive awareness that in this
definition self-consciousness was only
submerged and not preserved the
individual human being in relation to
God is is really a nullity of noting God
becomes the sole subject this whole
thing that really has pure actuality and
activity on the other hand the opposite
view which claims the thought is such
universality as such is the very same
simplicity is undifferentiated unmoved
substantiality so if I focus in on my my
own status as subject what I'm doing is
I'm focusing in on something that it's
very hard to disable what is it to be a
human being what is it to be a subject
and then he says if thirdly thought does
United self with the being of substance
and the apprehends immediacy your
intuition is thinking the question is
still whether this does not fall back
into inert simplicity and does not
depict actuality in a non actual manner
so we're setting on a problematic here
Hegel is not solving an issue in this
this one he's actually laying out a
problematic for us and he's saying that
this is the heart of the problematic
that we have to understand the true as
substance and subject which means that
were ourselves already implicated in it
and not only are we implicated in it but
other subjects are also implicated in it
we could talk about interest
subjectivity of other individual beings
but you know from early on we're also
talking about the divine as being itself
a subject and then the question is well
how the hell am I related to the divine
I'm actually the one who's who's
grasping it I'm the one who is
developing some some knowledge of it
whatever knowledge I may be able to
develop how is that happening and this
he's going to leave as a set of problems
to explore